[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight a little overview here's
where we are as of 8:00 p.m. Eastern
which is to say right now in many places
in this country Americans cannot go to
the park with their children they can't
go to church they can't have family
dinners with their relatives they can't
go to the dentist they can't get a knee
replacement they can't get married tens
of millions of them can't afford to do
much of anything right now because
they're unemployed but they better not
complain about it if they voice their
complaints online they're liable to be
censured by the tech companies if they
complain in public they could be
arrested and a number of them have been
the whims of our political leaders are
now unquestioned law dissent has been
banned and that ban is relentlessly
enforced by the willing Stooges in our
media who have finally stopped
pretending they don't hate you they
definitely do what country is this well
it's a country in a lockdown we're told
we have no choice but to do this to stop
our lives completely mass quarantine if
they tell us again and again are the
only way to save lives but that's a lie
they don't know it's true despite what
they claim there is no scientific record
to consult it's never been done we're
currently living through the largest and
most expensive experiment ever conducted
in human history we have spent trillions
of dollars and crushed millions of
people purely on the guess that a
nationwide lockdown would save us from
the corona virus as it worked was the
guest correct let's look at the data
that's where we should always begin it's
what our leaders should be consulting
daily here it is as of tonight eight US
states have not issued statewide
shelter-in-place orders for their
citizens those states are Arkansas Iowa
Nebraska
North Dakota Oklahoma South Dakota Utah
and Wyoming the question is have these
states suffered for not locking down and
the answer is no they haven't at least
not yet
currently all eight states are below the
national average in coronavirus cases
and deaths per capita that's not to say
they've been immune to the virus
they haven't been but they definitely
have not been hit harder than other
states now as
a matter of social science those eight
states are it is true on average smaller
and less dense in some cases much less
dense in the hardest-hit States but you
can adjust the numbers in a recent
article journalist and professor Wilfred
Riley did the math on this he compared
states that are locked down to states
without lock downs he then performed
statistical regressions that accounted
for population density income levels age
and racial diversity
he put his formulas right up there and
challenged people to run the same
numbers through those formulas or change
them come to a different conclusion if
they could no one has so far here's what
he found he found that a state's
lockdown strategy had virtually no
effect on how severe its outbreak of the
Wuhan coronavirus was are you surprised
by this maybe it shouldn't be you can
see the same trend at work in other
countries Sweden most famously has never
locked down restaurants there have never
closed that country is still suffering
from coronavirus suffering more in fact
than we are here in the US but the
country's epidemic appears to have
peaked and without locking down Sweden
and this is the key has fared far better
than other European countries that did
lockdown that includes Britain Italy
Spain Belgium how can this be true it
seems to contravene everything we hear
all day long
lockdowns stop the virus that's what
they tell us almost always at high
volume and with maximum outrage and
self-righteousness daring us to disagree
but in fact there's not much evidence
that it's true
consider the state of California which
is one of the first states to shut down
in a televised statement Los Angeles
Mayor Eric Garcetti bragged that his
city was under his absolute personal
control and for that reason the corona
virus would not spread there anyone who
disobeyed him would be hunted down
that's literally the phrase Garcetti
used watch this this has really been
marvelously embraced by 99.9% of people
we see it in the traffic data we see it
in the cellphone data but we're gonna
hunt down that last point 1% and say you
got to get inside you got cut it out and
you got a distance we're gonna hunt down
people who are outside they
years calling Donald Trump a fascist if
only Garcetti you may have just heard
bragged that he was surveilling people's
cars and tracking their cell phone use
but even that wasn't far enough for him
Garcetti also intentionally ruined its
city parks in Los Angeles just so that
nobody could use them without his
personal authorization we saw this week
for instance at the skate park at Venice
Beach and people were there so we had to
put sand into the skate park to make
that unusable for now when we come out
of this we'll clean that sound out no
modern political leader in this country
has ever talked like this ever and yet
suddenly in cities across the nation so
many of them are talking just like that
it's authoritarian has this new
authoritarianism produced results apart
from a surge of power for the
politicians exercising it well let's see
again to the numbers a new study by
researchers at USC University Southern
California tested large groups of people
in Los Angeles County for coronavirus
antibodies they found that as of early
April up to 5.6 percent of the entire
county had contracted the illness that
means up to 320,000 adults in Los
Angeles apparently had already had it at
the time the official number of infected
people was about 8,000 city officials
had no clue they weren't even close the
virus had spread throughout a huge
population right in the middle of the
most restrictive quarantine in American
history what does that tell you it tells
you the lockdown didn't work the
question is why exactly did it fail and
we don't know we can only guess maybe
people ignored the requirements of it or
maybe full enforcement of it was
impossible despite the fact they were
tracking people's cars and cell phones
or maybe forcing people to stay inside
all day isn't actually a good way to
contain a virus
whatever the reason that it failed it
did our leaders guessed wrong they
claimed that a lockdown would halt the
spread of the virus it did not do that
not even close and they need to admit
that and then we need to change our
approach based on the science not on
their whims on the numbers on what we've
learned
but we're not doing that public
officials are instead by and large
ignoring any evidence that indict s--
their policies or critically that might
threaten their new and much-loved power
they don't want to know what the facts
are indeed some of them are even now
right now promising even longer
lockdowns ones that extend maybe through
the end of the summer and even tougher
punishments for those who disobey them
they're deploying drones to catch people
who dare to go outside Americans this is
insanity
it is definitely and this cannot be
stated emphatically enough it is
definitely not science this is not
science it has nothing to do with the
public's health much less the broader
public interest this is instead what
happens when mediocre people suddenly
find themselves with godlike power
deciding who can go outside when people
can get married which medical procedures
you're allowed to have that's a feeling
of omnipotence and they like that
feeling it fills an empty place inside
they don't want to give it up they want
it to last forever even as the country
dies but it can't last forever because
it's not their country it's ours